paris hilton it's official she's a
married woman and i was with the
emotional mother of the bride kathy
hilton breaking it all down by the
numbers in this et exclusive
i'm just
overwhelmed yeah just one second one
second yeah kathy teared up on the
emotional and busy day her glam included
getting her hair washed in the kitchen
sink maid of honor nikki looked on mere
hours before paris's extravagant die
dues to carter reem how many guests 250.
how many different dresses will we see
paris in three
turns out it was four pamela roland for
this reception gown and paris was in
oscar de la renta as dad rick walked her
down the aisle i gotta ask
what's the budget on a paris hilton
wedding dress they don't compete
kathy's sisters kyle and kim richards
were in attendance along with other
stars from paris simple life are you
allowed to have blonde hair
kim k came solo no kanye or pete so did
bestie nicole richie other guests emma
roberts with friend kate hudson as well
as singers paula abdul who did a duet
with kathy bebe rexa and evan ross
[Music]
the official wedding singers kim petras
performed paris single while demi lovato
sang a whitney classic
but not everything went according to
plan we changed a lot last minute thank
goodness she loved the tablecloth nuage
and i designed this fabulous
tablecloth
this is like my wedding too yes kathy
helped design every detail all caught on
camera for paris in love hilton's
wedding docu-series streaming now on
peacock
she is down to the wire it was so funny
we were at mark's garden uh looking at
the flowers then we added more 80 000
roses and peonies the party continues
tonight at the famous santa monica pier
but are kids next for the bride and
groom more grand babies in the house i'm
more than ready
do you know how many kids they want to
have probably three or four well for now
we toast with paris's specialty moet
cocktail
to paris and carter oh cheers
[Music]